- castex il me rappelle pierre richard
dans la chèvre presse depuis que le mec
il arrive et c'est quand même tous les
jours il a vraiment le pauvre la de
l'envoyer nous raconter regard déjà sa
teinte frère il a plus de me filer un
psycho logiquement affecté à baisser ça
s'est passé parce à ccc génétique à lomé
c'est dur doit d'annoncer moi j'suis pas
d'accord ce calibre c'est à dire que il
y à il ya des gens qui donnent des
pointages et on était déjà prévenu que
même nous dans le théâtre
moi j'avais vendu des places et touche
les ibères ont reparlé on les fait
et d'annoncer aux gens et le public je
dois avouer je remercie vraiment les
français ils sont quand même au rendez
vous ils sont hyper solidaire pour les
restaurateurs mais comme les spectacles
10 ans du 27
y'a pas de soucis ouais je remercie
pauline un qui m'a donné l'idée pour
donc enfin comme burger king
on avait parlé il ya quelques semaines
il faut être honnête intellectuellement
ils ont toujours dit on verra le 15
décembre est matière à rapport aux
objectifs
aujourd'hui il faut pas pleurer on n'a
pas atteint les objectifs on est au
double au double on a diminué de 5000
donc c'est normal que les chéris oui
isabelle magnier une remarque de gesink
qui m'a frappé c'est très vrai ce que
vous dites on part la ministre comme si
c'était notre voisin mais eux-mêmes tout
huit mille fois plus qu'avant comme
s'ils étaient de la vraie vie tout le
temps isabelle je suis désolé de vous
annoncer ça mais moi je pense que le
vrai travail de marlène schiappa c'est
instagram meuse tandis que vraiment j'ai
jamais vu quelqu'un autant sur les
réseaux que de travailler et sur des
sujets aussi graves et importants tandis
que ce qui se passe je laisse de côté
des moules
moi je veux pas que les ministres il
soit cool ou accessible je me suis en
tout cas ils travaillent qu'ils aillent
dans le sens de tout leur faisait
craindre et sajoo vous répondre mais
c'est un connard